i'm garrick roleman a professional
educator at r studio and the author of
two books on r i've put together these
videos to teach you some of the main
ideas of doing data wrangling with r and
the tidy verse
if you're not familiar with the tidy
verse it's a collection of r packages
that are designed to help you do data
science
in this series of short videos we'll
walk through some of the most useful
tools for wrangling your data with r
also keep in mind that you can skip
around these videos to the tool that you
want by clicking the jump two links in
the video description
so there's one last thing that you
will probably want to do is you wrangle
your data with these packages and that's
combine multiple data sets into the same
data set
there's a simple way to combine data
sets together in r
if your data sets were meant to go
together
you can add them together by pasting one
as extra columns onto the first with the
buying calls command from d player
there's also a c bind command in base r
bind calls is just a little more
optimized
so
that's why i'm showing you bind calls
this is somewhat dangerous to do r has
no way of checking whether the rows are
in the same order between the data sets
or whether
when you combine the data together the
row
describes an observation that
observation that makes sense for example
here you probably want b to be on the
second line it's in the first line so
use column binding with caution make
sure the data is arranged for you to do
what you want to do
you could add the second data set as
additional rows to the bottom of your
first data set with bind rows or r bind
and base r
again you need to make sure that the
variables are in the same order and mean
the same thing but it's probably less
risky than column binding
and then if you actually have two data
sets like this where they describe the
same variables these have different
observations those variables
you could actually use set operations on
these data sets so
data frame set operations come with
dplyr you take two data frames and get
the union of rows that appear in both
data frames
the intersection of rows appear in both
data frames
and the set difference of rows that
appear in both data frames
that's just your basic union
intersection set different things
applied to data frames
now normally when you want to put data
sets together you need to do something a
little more involved and that's what i
call joining data
so here's a trivial example here's two
data frames they both talk about the
beatles
one's a list of songs and who wrote each
of the songs then one's a list of the
artists in the beelze and what each one
played or one of the instruments they
played and if you wanted to put these
things together into the same data set
so you match up the instrument that each
beatle played
with you know what song they wrote
you can do that with the left join
what left join does is it takes the
names of two data frames and then it
takes some joining criteria these would
be the name or names or columns that
both data sets share
and then what it will do is it'll
go through the second data frame find
the pieces of information that apply to
rows in the first data frame and add
them where they belong in that data
frame so order is not preserved the
second data frame's order is not
preserved first day frame yes that is
preserved but things are moved around to
supply a play column that actually makes
sense with your data frame and at the
end you have rows in your your output
that describe a unified observation john
both wrote across the universe and
played guitar
guitar had to appear twice
because john is also in the second row
and so it appears twice
there's no information about this last
row buddy holly who made piggy sue so
for the place called necketts and n a
there's nothing we could put there
left joins aren't the only way to join
data together in an intelligent fashion
you could do a right join well
this would be the syntax where if you
want to join based on two two columns
both first and last
use the c to make a vector of column
names and pass that to by
let's left join
left join isn't the only way to join
data sets together you could do an inner
join which is a little more exclusive so
an interjoint still puts the data sets
together in the same fashion but if
there's any row from the first data
frame that doesn't have information in
the second data frame like peggy sue and
buddy holly didn't appear in the second
day frame inner join will exclude that
from the results it just contains the
rows to appear in both data frames
uh
and then let me come back to this oh
oh yeah
i'm sorry uh so we just released two new
joins in the slides you'll find them on
a cheat sheet those are right join and
outer join so right join is like a left
join
but
it's it's has the same effect as if you
switch the the order of the day frames
appear if you put artist first and song
second that would give you the
equivalent of a right join the second
data frames prioritize are the first an
outer join is the complement of an inner
join an inner join only keeps the rows
up here in both data frames an outer
join keeps every row that appears in any
data frame and you get a very big day
frame at the end but that play has a
bunch of missing values
you could look those up on the cheat
sheet
then we have two filtering joints
semi-join and anti-join these don't
actually join data sets together at all
they just take the first day set and
remove rows from it
based on what appears in the second
dataset so what semi-join will do is
i'll take the first data set look at the
data and see which rows have an
equivalent in the second data set
and return just those rows that have an
equivalent it doesn't add anything to
the rows it just shows you what rows
will actually be joined should you do a
join
an
anti does the opposite it shows you
which rows do not have equivalent in the
second data set so you can use antijoin
to see which rows will not be joined
when you do drawing
so am i joined in antijoin are good ways
to sort of debug or get a feel for how
the join is going to work ahead of time
all right
so
let's skip over some of this recap
begin near the top of the hour so i just
want to point your attention to where
you can learn more this cheat sheet is a
really great and concise way to go about
learning how to wrangle data with these
two packages you can download it here at
this link we also have other cheat
sheets about other things there
if you want to practice with dplyr
there's a course that i've made with
data camp that has about four hours
worth of content on dplyr there's some
video lessons it's a live coding
environment and mostly it has lots and
lots of practice so this is a good place
to go if you want to practice it does
cost i think 95 or so
thanks for checking out our data
wrangling video series this is just one
video in a larger set of resources on
data wrangling so here are links to all
of our other videos in this series and
again have a look at the video
description for shortcuts to other parts
of the series as well as other resources
we think might be helpful like cheat
sheets and further documentation
we hope you find all these resources
useful and if you do as always we would
appreciate a thumbs up or a share both
go a long way to helping this content
reach people who could benefit from it